just got back to the office
while you were gone we had an irie time
while you were gone Jim glued my desk
drawers together he changed my voicemail
so that my voice sounded like a chipmunk
he told me that we had a meeting at 4am
and I was the only one who showed up
Dwight he turned over please I just got
back from vacation man all right so
chill
let's don't don't hush my mellow man
what is this what happened here
I don't know
oh this does not look good did anyone
see what happened around my desk area
this morning what I really think
someone's probably just playing a prank
on you so just go right through it a
prank huh this is official police line
tape okay it's not a prank probably is
damn it people someone must have seen
something
how you people are useless in Jesus
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
hold please
Dwight it's the sheriff he said that
it's really important it's regarding
your desk I'll transfer oh no no
[Music]
um
just cut through it this is why I am a
volunteer sheriff's deputy and you are
not that is not why
come on man he really wants to get in
touch with you maybe it's a murder no
there's no blood maybe poison possibly
my God
[Music]
no just no
Sheriff this is volunteer sheriff's
deputy Dwight Schrute press the pound
key
what's your 20.
what is this thing you just sent me
what's really cool it's a picture of the
most relaxing Meadow you've ever seen
I know what this is It's supposed to
lull me into a sense of calm and then a
ghoul pops up and scares me why would I
do that Dwight of all people I know that
you're unscurable damn right I am
foreign
looking at you right now
oh no scary goal just popped up I'm so
scared I'm so scared really is this the
best you could
Jim how are you guys
[Music]
okay
that is the best I can do
all right let's start all right
sure what I'm supposed to be doing but
you are my producer your suit I am the
creative genius you take care of all the
boring stuff and let my mind just run
free yep now we have 85 dollars and a
SAM goody gift certificate and we need
to be done by 9am tomorrow why don't you
start by telling me what you got we
start
on a single blank sheet of paper love it
and we widen to reveal ancient Rome
can't do that
okay we widen to reveal a spaceship
blasting out of a woman's womb
definitely can't do that
man you know what okay Scott why don't
you take your head out of the clouds and
come back down to planet Earth so we can
make a commercial
ah
I'm just doing my job man if you don't
let me pursue my artistic Vision I'm
going to walk good fine I've got one
Andy Bernard that will direct this puppy
for half your fee no no don't don't no I
can't I can do it do it good I can do it
good
please don't
please please
okay make a commercial
do you want this open or closed closed
any signatures here two three if I count
myself nice you're almost there and
it'll be four when you sign it three and
do it
did you ever think and I'm just
speculating here that maybe you're part
of the problem I think I would know if I
was part of the problem Julie of two
signatures three
okay
if I was part of the problem and I'm
just speculating here
or would you suggest I do
you have a great smile
and lights up a room
let's see the smile
tends your chin
put your neck back a bit
yeah great now give me a wink
perfect
you got me
foreign
in the original Matrix movie seeing the
same cat twice was a glitch in the
system it was proof that the Matrix was
real
training the cat was both easier and
more boring than I thought it would be
involve putting down little piles of
treats
the cat barely cared that it had to run
through the ceiling
why didn't we just get two black cats
turns out Glenn in the warehouse has a
twin brother that Dwight doesn't know
about
Ben
so we threw them in too
this just came for you
hello meet me in the warehouse but watch
out for the men in reception
there's no man that was
meet me in the warehouse
foreign
that is the name I allowed you to know
me by while I watched over you waiting
for the time to approach
that time has come
and now you may know my real name
dorotheus dorotheus I'm morpheus's
brother
but the Matrix isn't real it's a Trilogy
of flawless life-changing films and an
online game the first Matrix movie was a
program written by my team to prepare
people for the truth but then the
machines countered with their own
program to make it seem as if a piece
was achieved so
there is no peace there is not oh that
is terrible news Dwight we need your
help I would like you to join my
underground Army and help us wage war
for the freedom of all humankind
Hank is good on his feet right I told
you he nail it
you will stay in The Matrix you will
remember none of this Life Will Go On as
it is for you
put your eyes
you will see just how deep the rabbit
hole goes
I'll take the blue pill
wait now the blue will keep you in the
program the Reds the cool one I
understand I like the blue pill please
you were very clear it's just
you know I really appreciate the work
that you and your brother are doing
appreciates too small a word but the
timing is terrible right now they just
promoted me to manager plus I own this
building I run a very substantial farm
and I'm getting married soon to a woman
a love and okay yeah maybe that love Is
Just zeros and ones but
I don't want to lose it
no one hates machines more than me
but
truly happy
are you kidding me I hired 30 people
if the blue pill is not safe to swallow
someone to tell us now